today on the matt wall show youtube
begins a major censorship campaign as
the media finally discovers that there
might be something to the whole hunter
biden story
of course they make this discovery only
after the election coincidentally i'm
sure also five headlines including a
michigan lawmaker
making essentially death threats against
trump supporters and
joe biden announces his plans to make
the military
more diverse and inclusive that'll help
us if we end up in a war with china
and today i must cancel i'm afraid the
cartoon network all of that
and more coming up today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know as we're all uh online this
this this holiday season
you know you're buying gifts you're
putting a lot of your financial
information out there
it's never been more important to focus
on protecting
your online data new research from
threat intelligence firms reveals that
cyber criminal groups are increasingly
using ransomware
and changing their tactics techniques
and procedures to widen the scope of
their cyber attacks
which greatly expands their pool of
victims it's important just to
understand how
cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives and this is just one
of the ways especially this holiday
season you know where like i said you're
you're online
you're putting your credit card
information out there you're uh you know
giving more of your personal information
maybe than you normally would
and but the problem is if you're just
monitoring your credit checking bank
statements
there are a lot of identity threats that
you're going to miss that's why you need
lifelock which is the leader
in identity theft protection that
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats
like your social security number being
for sale and dark web if you detect
if they detect your information uh is
used on the network they will send you
an alert
and here's the other thing if you do
become a victim of identity threat like
identity theft rather as so many
millions of americans have been
lifelock can help restore your identity
easier
than than you'd be able to do on your
own you don't want to deal with
something like that
on your own without having uh this
network of support like lifelock
so you've got to get lifelock now nobody
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but lifelock can help you
feel warm and protected this holiday
season and you can save up to 25
off your first year by going to
lifelock.com wallace that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off well two things
happened yesterday to further
reveal what we already knew about big
tech and big media and how they conspire
to censor and manipulate the public the
first was a major announcement from
youtube
the company announced it would be
removing any videos that allege
widespread voter fraud you're not
allowed to go on youtube and express the
opinion
that the election was stolen youtube has
made an editorial decision
which it would have every right to do if
it was a publisher
publishers make editorial decisions all
the time the daily wire publishes lots
of content every day it can decide
what sort of content it wants to publish
what sort of opinions or viewpoints it
wants to put out there what sorts of
opinions it doesn't want to put out
there
the problem is that youtube just like
facebook and twitter
claims to be a platform not a publisher
it claims that it is merely hosting the
content merely
providing a home for uh people to post
content
its role is neutral it says that line
has
been clearly untenable for a while but
youtube's announced decision yesterday
completely blew their own previous
rationalizations apart
i listen to this statement from youtube
announcing the policy and tell me if it
doesn't sound exactly like a publisher
explaining you know its editorial
guidelines essentially here's what it
said
quote yesterday was the safe harbor
deadline for the u.s presidential
election and enough states have
certified their election results to
determine a president-elect given that
we will start removing any piece of
content uploaded today or anytime after
that misleads people by alleging that
widespread fraud or error changed the
outcome of the
2020 u.s presidential election in line
with our approach towards historical u.s
presidential elections
for example we will remove videos
claiming that a presidential candidate
won the election due to widespread
software glitches or counting errors we
will begin enforcing this policy
policy today and we'll ramp it up in the
coming weeks
it doesn't matter what you think about
the voter fraud question
the point is that some people have the
opinion that the election was stolen
that there was fraud et cetera and if
youtube is a neutral platform then they
should be able to express that opinion
on it
yet it's not a neutral platform and that
is why
you may have noticed youtube has for the
past four years played host to
many many videos alleging that donald
trump stole the election in 2016
that he's not a legitimate president
that he's in cahoots with russia and so
on
i mean they said this is in line with
their historical approach to
presidential elections oh really
i went to youtube before the show
searched searched for just like two
seconds
and i found this video on youtube watch
i believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president
he knows he knows that there were
a bunch of different reasons why the
election turned out the way it did and i
take responsibility for those parts of
it that i should but jane it was like
applying for a job and getting 66
million
letters of recommendation and losing to
a corrupt human tornado and so i know
that he knows that this wasn't on the
level
i don't know that we'll ever know
everything that happened but clearly we
know
a lot and are learning more every day
and history will probably sort it all
out so of course he's obsessed with me
and i believe that it's a guilty
conscience in so much as he has a
conscience
a corrupt human tornado right if donald
trump is a corrupt human tornado
then hillary clinton is the whole damn
hurricane um so that's that's
speaking of not having a conscious but
conscience but um
that sounds what you just heard there
sounds an awful lot like hillary clinton
alleging
that trump stole the election if trump
is an illegitimate president
that would mean that he won the election
by fraud of some kind
if he won the election legitimately then
he's a legitimate president
that's what hillary clinton is claiming
here um it's what she's claimed
repeatedly over the past four years is
what the media has claimed the democrats
have claimed
and yet their videos remain up their
posts have not been taken down
they're not censored so always remember
this
very few of the people currently ringing
their hands about trump undermining the
integrity of our election
by claiming fraud actually have the
moral authority
or credibility to be outraged about it
almost all of them
have been doing exactly the same thing
relentlessly for years
and this is just one example of
censorship and manipulation by
big tech and big media to come out of
yesterday here's the other
if you go to google right now type in
the words hunter biden
an amazing thing will happen now you
recall that up until this moment
if you typed in hunter biden you would
uh
you would find mostly a bunch of
articles from mainstream media sources
telling us that all the stuff about
hunter biden
and biden family corruption was a bunch
of fake news
you find fact checkers debunking it
articles explaining why the whole thing
is
really nothing at all and if you went to
twitter or facebook you'd find
not much about hunter biden at all
because most of the subjects
uh you know were most of the the posts
on that subject were taken down
in the most massive and coordinated
censorship campaign we'd ever seen
up to that point now youtube is going to
try to give it a run for its money
though but now today go to google type
in hunter biden
and you get tons of headlines posted
just today or last night saying stuff
like this here are some examples
federal criminal investigation into
hunter biden focuses on his business
dealings in china
justice department's interests and
hunter biden covered more than taxes
joe biden's son hunter biden under
federal investigation for tax case
hunter biden tax affairs under federal
investigation links to china funds
emerge
sources say hunter biden tax probe
examining chinese business dealings
and on and on now what happened i'm old
enough to remember four weeks ago
when the hunter biden story was fake
news
so fake that twitter had to ban you if
you talked about it
now here's what a cnn article and
they're one of the headlines i mentioned
before
but a cnn article published this morning
this is what they this is this is their
report they say
quote after going quiet in the months
before the election federal authorities
are now actively investigating the
business dealings of hunter biden a
person with knowledge of the probe said
his father president-elect joe biden is
not implicated
now that the election is over the
investigation is entering a new face
federal prosecutors in delaware working
with the irs criminal investigation
agency and the fbi are taking overt
steps such as issuing subpoenas and
seeking interviews
activity investigation had gone had gone
covert in recent months due to justice
apartment guidelines
prohibiting overt actions that could
affect an election the person said
it then goes on to say quote
investigators have been examining
multiple financial issues including
whether hunter biden
and his associates violated tax and
money laundering laws in business
dealings in foreign countries
principally china according to two
people briefed on the probe
oh so in other words the original report
from new york post
which was banned on twitter and
condemned or ignored by outlets like cnn
was correct
the justice department just didn't want
to confirm it because they didn't want
to
effect an election but they didn't want
to affect it how
with the truth what they're telling us
is that
they were afraid the truth might
influence our vote so they decided not
to tell us the truth
to me that sounds an awful lot like
affecting an election
if you're going to affect an election
with the truth or not the truth
better to affect it with the truth in
fact elections are supposed to be
affected by the truth of course
with or without the justice department
though the evidence of hunter biden's
corruption was
clear as day the new york post was
trying to tell us about it it's just
that they were prevented from doing so
sam stein of the daily beast posted a
link to an article today
and writes quote evidence of a mundering
money laundering probe into hunter biden
was apparent in the markings on a series
of documents that were made public
but went largely unnoticed in the days
leading up to the november election
largely unnoticed sam huh why is that
you're in the news media isn't it your
job to
notice these things and make sure
everyone else notices them
it's clear now just as it was clear all
along that the hunter biden story is
real was always real
the corruption in the biden family goes
deep um
but there was a conspiracy yes an actual
conspiracy
to hide and cover up this information so
as to ensure that biden is elected
now the election is over there they'll
let the floodgates open no need to hold
back the river now
they already got the guy they wanted
what the media
and big tech have done here may not
qualify as
election fraud in the legal sense and if
it did i guess i wouldn't be allowed to
say it without this show getting removed
from youtube
but this is certainly a form of meddling
of interfering of
undermining our election and this is the
form of election interference
that will be i think our biggest
obstacle in the future forget about
rigging ballots
they don't need to rig the ballots if
they can first rig the dissemination
and spread of information if they can
manipulate the public into filling out
the ballots how they want
that's all they need to do and that's
their game now
and our republic will suffer because of
it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
yes by the way earlier you may have
picked up on it um as i was saying
hunter biden i did
i did slip up and accidentally call him
humper biden that did happen
make of that what you will um let's go
to number one
michigan state representative cynthia
johnson has been
stripped of her committee assignments
for posting a video where she explicitly
threatens violence against trump
supporters
uh let's take a listen to that here it
is so this is just a warning to
you trumpers
be careful walk lightly
we ain't playing with you enough
of the shenanigans
enough is enough and for those of you
who are soldiers you know how to do it
do it right be in order
make them pay love y'all
bye-bye i like the i love you all
bye-bye at the end
make them pay anyway love you bye-bye
talk to you later um now she
did post uh a follow-up now that to me i
listen to that
and sounds like she's calling on
soldiers to
make them pay that being they being
trump supporters sounds like a call to
violence to me
um and but she did post a follow-up
to that video where she tried to i guess
clarify what she meant by soldiers
and uh here's the clarification all you
soldiers soldiers
of christ soldiers against
racism soldiers against
misogyny soldiers against
domestic violence and domestic
terrorism soldiers
rise it's time for you to rise
soldiers
soldiers for christ hmm
soldiers against racism
soldiers against misogyny
soldiers four
black and brown people who are being
mistreated rise
soldiers soldiers against hate
soldiers against arthritis
soldiers against head lice
we're just going through all the bad
things that we have that's what you
meant by soldiers um so anyway we could
see from that video that uh
it's it's this does actually i think it
does clarify things
in that she's obviously insane this is
an insane person
who's been she you know i don't know how
long she's been
in the michigan state legislature i i'm
assuming she's probably been elected you
know 15 times
um and uh but she's just completely out
of her mind
and the the uh penalty
is that she loses her committee
assignments
that's got to be nice that's got to be
nice that you know you can
blatantly call for violence and the
worst thing that happens is you lose
your committee assignments
uh no i think that we need more than
committee assignments taken away
this to me is she should go to jail for
that
you're not allowed to do that that's not
free speech you can't you cannot
openly explicitly uh try to incite
violence against the law
especially when you're elected leader
somehow
so yeah there should be criminal
penalties that go beyond
losing your committee assignments it
would seem to me all right governor
cuomo
uh doing his favorite thing yesterday
talking to the cameras
called for a public education campaign
to battle the scourge of
vaccine skepticism here he is
first we're gonna have to have a real
public education campaign to
battle the skepticism uh just think of
the math
on this you have to get to 75 to 85
of the overall population vaccinated for
the vaccine to be effective
75 to 85 percent 50
of the population says right now they
don't want to take the vaccine
they don't trust the approval process uh
they're worried about vaccines in
general but 50
are now saying they don't want to take
the vaccine you cannot get to
75 if 50
don't take it that's even i can do that
math
uh so we're going to need a real public
education to dispel
the skepticism that already exists
okay so he wants to combat he wants to
battle the skepticism
maybe he can call up some of us cynthia
johnson's soldiers for that
soldiers against skepticism um
but i would suggest that if he wants to
deal with skepticism the first person
needs to talk to the first skeptic
the first vaccine skeptic he needs to do
battle with
is himself here is andrew cuomo a few
weeks ago
sounding rather skeptical skeptical
about the vaccine listen
about you last night say that he trusts
the experts at the fbi
at the fda how confident are you in the
approval process of the fda right now
well first uh how confident am i uh
i'm not that confident but my opinion
doesn't matter i don't believe the
american people
are that confident you're going to say
to the american people now
here's a vaccine it was new it was done
quickly
but trust this federal administration
and their health
administration that it's safe
and we're not 100 sure of the
consequences
i think it's going to be a very
skeptical american public about taking
the vaccine and they should be
and they should be and they should be
what an absolute fraud this guy is
like absolutely oh my goodness
um they sh that was a few weeks ago
before the election the the the the the
public should be skeptical he says and
now he's saying well we got to do
something about all the skepticism
that i was just encouraging 15 seconds
ago
um and what what does he say in that
clip what does he say that the
skepticism should be
tied to like what are the reasons why
people should be
skeptical he said because it's it's it's
it's a
it's being rushed that's his words it's
being rushed
the vaccine's coming out so quickly
reason to be skeptical about
that according to him and he also says
that we should um
our trust of the vaccine should hinge
in large part on how much we trust the
federal administration
okay and he trusts the by demonstration
he doesn't
trust trump but there's
gonna be 50 of the population at least
who doesn't trust the biden
administration
and he's the one who said you know our
trust for the vaccine should uh
should be hinged on that now speaking of
vaccines i don't know if this will get
me labeled in the skeptic camp or not
but i did want to report since we're on
the subject and this seems important to
me from the daily mail this is what
they're reporting
four people who got pfizer's coronavirus
vaccine in the firm's trial developed
bell
developed bell's palsy a form of
temporary facial paralysis according to
u.s regulators who gave the report on
the shot
fda regulators said there wasn't any
clear way that the vaccine caused bell's
palsy
but warned that doctors should watch for
the alarming side effects
and pfizer should continue to keep tabs
on how many people it strikes
no one knows what exactly causes bell's
palsy which
resolves on its own most of the time
well there's just information i'm
putting out there um
and this is why as as i've said all
along
my my own approach or my view of the
chronovirus vaccine is
read the information on it look at all
the information good and bad
um make a judgment based on that also
make a judgment based on
whether you're in a a demographic where
you feel like you need the vaccine
that's my that's my view on it
if that means that 85 of people get it
fine if that means 50 percent do
fine people should be able to do what
they want
and this is by the way been my view of
vaccines all along in general
i'm often asked you know what is what's
your position on vaccines how do you
feel about vaccines i don't have a
position
on vaccines it's kind of like asking me
um what what's your position on drugs on
prescription drugs
i don't like all of them i'm not against
all them either
if you need a prescription drug and it's
prescribed by a doctor who you trust and
you really do need it and you know
you've done the research on it then take
it don't take it too much don't take
any old drug that someone mentions to
you
i feel the same way about vaccine i'm
not dogmatic about it and that's how i
think we should approach this
all right let's um we'll stay on the
covet topic here joe biden again
revealing his uh masking plan
and he's already talked a little bit
about this but here he lays it out in uh
with a little bit more detail
uh this is joe biden explaining his
masking plan here it is watch
my first 100 days is going to require
i'm going to ask for a masking plan
everyone for the first hundred days of
my administration to wear a mask
it will start with my sign in order on
day one to require
masks where i can under the law
like federal buildings interstate travel
on planes
trains and buses i'll also be working
with the governors and mayors
to do the same in their states and their
cities
we're going to require mask wherever
possible
okay so there you go 100 days that's his
100 day masking plan
uh i'll say two things about it number
one i look forward to ignoring it
i i don't care what the president's i
appreciate him sharing his opinion on
whether i should be wearing a mask
doesn't really matter to me though um he
can give me his opinion
but i don't respect the president's
authority to tell me what i should be
wearing on my face
i just don't so i i look forward to uh
to you know listening to his ideas on
that subject
and probably ignoring them personally
but
why a hundred days you know 100 days of
masking
why why that why 100 days we asked this
before
why not 105 days why not 90 days why not
75 why not a thousand
why where do you come up with 100 and we
know that there have been a lot of just
arbitrary
numbers that have been pulled out that
we all remember 15 days to slow the
spread which was really six months or
seven or eight months whatever however
however many uh however long it's been
at this point but i think
probably with a hundred days it's it's
not entirely arbitrary
there is there is a strategy behind it
you think about 100 days from the
inauguration
where does that get us it gets us to
what like
may right gets us into the spring and we
know that the chronovirus is
seasonal that it ebbs and flows with the
seasons
we've got a surge right now it's within
the cold temperatures it was
uh it dipped during the this the spring
and summer
so the way he's got this set up is that
100 days of masking
at the end of that 100 days there is
going to be a dip
a sizable dip in coronavirus cases
because of the season
and we know that for sure but he set it
up so that
when that comes seasonally he can say
you see my 100 day plan
save lives even though there's no reason
to think it'll have anything to do with
his 100-day plan
so i think that's part of the strategy
here if i'm not giving him too much
credit for being
for being clever at least if not also
dishonest
number four a report from the new yorker
says several sources inside the senate
say dianne feinstein who's 87
struggles to remember briefings just
after they take place and that her
cognitive decline has been evident for
several years
so you know no big deal just a high
ranking senator
in cognitive decline 87 years old
i read this and i and i i just think
what
it is crazy that we allow someone at the
age of 87
to hold elected office in any capacity
let alone
at that high uh high of a level
87 years old do you know after 85
i think it's over 30 percent of people
after the age of 85 develop
develop alzheimer's 30
so if you look at any average 87 year
old there's around a 30
chance that they have alzheimer's that
that's
that's nothing against older people it's
not an insult it's just this is where
we're all headed
because we are mortal beings and we're
not going to live forever
and when you get to be in your 80s you
are towards the end of your life
and on average the end of your life is
going to come up pretty shortly
that's what that's the situation we all
are in but there are just certain
realities of being an older person this
is one of them
that you start to lose your mental and
physical capacities
that will happen to everyone if you
don't die before
those are the two options
um it's you know that's what it is live
long enough to lose your mind
or die before that happens those are
sort of like the two options we have as
people
it's not great it's pretty depressing
but that's there it is
and yet we let people who are in this
like red zone where where where lots of
them are going to start losing their
minds
we let them run for office it's crazy to
me
this is why i'm always you know we talk
about term limits um
i think term limits are a good idea but
also age limits there should be an age
limit forget about term limits age
limits
how about this this this to me seems
seems reasonable
75 is the cutoff after 75 you cannot run
for any federal office
so right and if we're talking about the
presidency
35 is is when you can start to run so
that gives you 40 years
35 to 75 that's 40 solid years to run
i think that's enough i think that's
enough of an allotment if you can't do
it in 40 years
that it wasn't for you uh the same goes
for the senate congress i just um
this there's no good reason
to have people in their 80s in public
office
i don't see any good reason for it
um five finally joe biden has nominated
lloyd austin as defense secretary and
here he is
explaining his uh reasoning behind it
listen
helping inform our efforts to ensure
that our armed forces reflect the full
strength and diversity
of our nation that black latino asian
american native american
women men lgbt service members
are treated with dignity and respect
you know at a time when more than 40
percent of our act
more than listen more than 40 percent of
our active duty forces
are people of color this long past time
the department's leadership
reflects that diversity why
why should it reflect that diversity
who cares who cares about the the
skin pigmentation of of people who are
leading the military
or leading the department of defense
and in in line with this the u.s special
operations command
has a twitter account and they tweeted
today um sort of lining up with uh with
biden's
priorities here they said diversity and
inclusion require
action it requires decisions and it
requires leaders that must put
themselves out there and must make
purposeful decisions
this is a quoting from general richard
clark
uh commander and he's speaking at some
sort of conference and then it ends with
diversity strengthens
does it though how does diversity
strengthen the military
you know my view is the people who run
the military
people in uh in commanding positions
should just be the people who are best
for the job i don't care what
they look like i don't care what's what
their skin color is
um who cares
and it really does trouble me i think it
should trouble all of us and scare all
of us
when we get this kind of woke sjw
nonsense from the military we get it
everywhere else in in society
but we get it from the military that's a
problem because it seems to me that
right now
with the people running the military our
military the american military
their focus is on diversity inclusion
tolerance while elsewhere in the world
like say probably in china uh they're
focused on making sure their military is
a killing machine
an efficient thorough killing machine
and that concerns me about our prospects
the next time we're
in a war with a real superpower like say
china
does anyone feel good about that i mean
when you when you go out onto the
battlefield against a a superpower
how does your tolerance and inclusion
help you
does it matter at all are we hoping the
enemy will just be like impressed with
it
and they'll throw down their arms and
give up surrender
i don't think that's gonna happen um
so but that's uh we've got we've got
biden now has
four years to uh to to further uh
really speed up this process of making
the military more resemble
say uh you know a gender studies class
a little concerned about that before we
get our date to our daily cancellation
today you know there's there's
there's if there are a few things more
important to your
general health and well-being and
happiness in life than getting a good
night's
sleep um i could tell you for for us
especially
that we've got four kids and if you're a
parent with young kids you've had a baby
or something you know that you don't get
to sleep a lot
so you've got to make use of the time in
fact my kids my my my two boys
uh we moved to tennessee and we moved an
hour back
you know we moved into it just an hour
back um because uh because
we're in a different time zone now my
boys somehow still have not adjusted to
that change so they're getting up at
like
before dawn every single morning and
that's why again
just when i'm sleeping i've gotta make
i've gotta really sleep
because i gotta get that sleep time in
and that's why i'm so glad that i have
my pillow uh my pillow is just
everything about my pillow all of their
products
are amazing uh and they're they're act
the actual pillows themselves the famous
pillows
they never go flat um you can wash and
dry them as many times as you want they
maintain their shape
and best of all they're made in the usa
and also best of all they're just
super comfortable and they will help you
sleep if you don't have a my pillow or
know someone who doesn't
doesn't doesn't now is the time because
of a limited time
offer mike is offering his premium my
pillows yes the ones that started it all
for his lowest price ever you can also
get a queen size
premium my pillow regularly to be 69.98
right now you can get it for only 29.98
that's a forty dollar
savings kings are only five dollars more
now is the time to buy we're getting
into the holiday season it's also a
great gift if you're looking for someone
uh
you know everyone would love a my pillow
as a gift so again
that's uh forty off on the my pillow
um 29.98 for a queen size premium my
pillow
you buy now and mike will extend his
60-day money-back guarantee
to march 1st 2021. you got to take
advantage of this go to mypillow.com
click on the radio listener square
there you'll find not only this amazing
offer but also deep discounts on all my
pillow products including the
giza dream bed sheets the my pillow
mattress topper
my pillow towel towel sets all of that
or you can call
800-651-1148 and use promo code
dailywire also
uh should mention speaking of the daily
wire
now is the time to become a daily wire
member if you do you can take advantage
of and you can get one of these coveted
leftist tiers tumblers we've got the new
the new and improved model um still does
basically the same thing but it looks a
lot nicer
and on top of that a lot of great
content as well the michael knowles show
is now five days a week we're adding
more content for members to enjoy we've
added the entire prageru catalog
to dailywire.com uh the entire catalog
will be there by the end of the year but
already you can get prageru's five
minute videos you can get the candace
owen show
from prageru kenis owens also will be
joining the daily wire soon
having a live studio audience um we've
got all kinds of stuff coming up
and that's why you want to go to
dailywire.com
subscribe now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so today we're going to cancel the
cartoon network you know
some of you young kids don't remember
this and probably can't imagine it but
there was a time when the cartoon
network was a network
that aired cartoons this was back in the
days when music television had music the
history channel had history
vh1 mostly played matchbox 20 videos and
you could watch all these things while
sitting in your bean bag chair
in your jinko shorts sipping on high c
or sunny d those were the days now
though everything in pop culture
just like everything in the broader
culture must be dedicated first and
foremost to preaching dogma even the
military as we just discussed
it's all televangelism now all the time
everywhere
and the religion being preached of
course most of the time is leftism
cartoons are no exception to this if
anything cartoons have become especially
preachy it hasn't happened yet but it
seems only a matter of time until mickey
mouse comes out as a
non-binary genderqueer pansexual
releases a psa to tell us about it
but in the meantime we have the cast
over at the cartoon network burying the
crown as the most
woke members of the animated community
the latest is an anti-racist psa posted
to the cartoon network's social media
channels
featuring something or someone called
the crystal gems or crystal gem i'm not
sure
what or who that is but it doesn't
matter here's the psa which by the way
has been shared 25
000 times on twitter alone here it is
all right class can anyone tell me who
invented the light bulb
that's not entirely true the light bulb
could more rightfully be attributed to
lewis latimer the black inventor behind
the filament
inside the bulb used invention made
light bulbs affordable and efficient
enough for the general public
bringing electric light into households
around the world
well so now you know
wait is that it hold on we're not going
to mention
why he invented the filament to create a
better standard of living for people who
had only just been freed from slavery
are we going to ask why kids are
apparently learning about thomas edison
and not learning about louis latimer
these textbooks are incomplete
there were black roman warriors black
medieval knights black classical
musicians black cowboys black fighter
pilot
where are they i worry about you humans
because you only live what about a
hundred years
you rely on these stories to know your
own history
thanks to systemic racism most of your
storytellers prioritize white
accomplishments which leaves you with an
incomplete picture
ask yourself is your learning history
who's telling the story
was this modified to make white readers
comfortable are major details being left
out that would credit people of color
and center their point of view
honestly i should have asked for script
approval before agreeing to do this
we'll do some rewrites i'm sorry we
didn't know well
so now you know i swear
[Music]
sure okay prioritizing white
accomplishments yeah
i remember that in school that was
always my favorite uh my favorite
subject white accomplishments that was
the subject they used to teach us in
school
um you know it was a whole whole subject
it was a whole chapter in the history
books
the white accomplishment chapter but
there you go
and now we know um where joe biden
got this we gotta for example
why in god's name don't we teach
history in history classes
a black man invented the light bulb not
a white guy named edison
okay there's so much did anybody know
before
what recently happened that black wall
street in oklahoma was burned to the
ground
anybody know these things we act because
we don't teach them
we got to give people facts
teach them what's out there i
i don't understand the whisper why is he
whispering first of all
sounds like he just completed a marathon
um but
a black guy invented the light bulb not
thomas edison he says there joe biden
this is why you can't let grandpa watch
too many cartoons he's very
easily influenced these days let's just
make sure he doesn't start watching
scooby-doo or else he'll want to defund
the police and replace them with
four high schoolers and a dog in a van
by the way
that cartoon network video links to an
anti-racism website which
says at the top cartoon network stands
behind anti-racism as part of our
commitment to fostering
inclusion and equity then it gives a
link to some resources
if we need them first of which is
something called the national black
justice coalition which we're told is
quote a civil rights organization
dedicated to the empowerment of black
lesbian
gay bisexual transgender queer and same
gender loving people including people
with hiv
aids so i want you to make sure you
update your woke verbiage glossary here
it is same gender loving now not same
sex loving the new acronym is it says
lgbtq slash sgl
we're now adding slashes to the
abbreviation there's also a plus
sign usually right lgbtq plus we just
need to add some parentheses
multiplication exponents pretty soon the
thing turns into a math equation
instead of just saying gay people you
have to do calculus
but what about the claim being made here
we're told that it's
not entirely true that thomas edison
invented the light bulb because the
invention
could more rightfully be attributed to a
black inventor named louis latimer
that presumably is the black guy that
joe biden mentioned
though you never know with him he could
have been referring to i don't know
tupac for all we know confused as he
tends to be these days
either way this is all nonsense and
you don't need to check wikipedia to
know that it's nonsense you heard it
from the cartoon lady in the video she
rightly points out that latimer
innovated a filament for the bulb he
didn't invent
the filament as is stated he wasn't the
first to come up with a film but
he did come up with a better longer
lasting filament
an important contribution no doubt but
that it does not equate to inventing the
light bulb
i could invent a more durable tire or
more reliable
braking system for your car but there's
no way that i can ever
invent your car the car was already
invented
that's been done as for the actual
inventor of the light bulb you know
there's a debate that could be had about
that
edison deserves most of the credit he
gets i think joseph swann
an english scientist also developed an
incandescent bulb independently
joseph swan though was white the fact is
this is just the fact many of the most
important inventions modern society
were given to us by white people usually
men
not all but a great many that's not a
racist statement it's just a fact
it's also not something to be ashamed of
or embarrassed or competitive about
may i suggest a different approach in
attitude actually how about gratitude
you know the evil white man gets blamed
for quite a lot especially historically
can we not also be grateful for the
amazing achievements
of white men why don't you say thank you
to thomas edison
instead of trying to figure out a way to
posthumously steal his invention from
him and give it to somebody else
but we live in such irrational times
that i will no doubt be accused of
racism
for saying that we should be grateful
for the many wonderful and essential
achievements of white men through
history
media matters is this moment i'm sure
furiously typing up an article about it
yet if i said we should be grateful for
the achievements of women
or native americans or pacific islanders
or jamaicans or
literally any other group at all nobody
would even consider calling it racist or
treating it as controversial
there is just one group only one group
that we are not allowed to say anything
positive about
ever and that's ridiculous and it's a
game that i'm just not going to play
yes white men did many great important
things
your life is better today because of
white men and you should be grateful two
white men
that's what i said i'll keep saying it
and i will laugh at your outrage and
treat it with the contempt it deserves
you know it's one thing to tear down the
statues and take the names off of
buildings as we discussed yesterday
that's bad enough but we're now entering
a phase
where the history books are rewritten
the record is altered in service to a
narrative
that demands that white men are only
evil and have never contributed
anything but bigotry and hate to society
before long you know they won't just be
taking jefferson's name off of schools
they're also going to pretend he didn't
write the declaration of independence
i wonder who will get the credit for
that in our revised account of history
frederick douglass maybe he was born
about 40 years too late but why should
that matter
the truth doesn't matter at all all that
matters
is the narrative which is informed by
ideology
not fact and for that reason
cartoon network is cancelled so we've
canceled cartoons we've cancelled santa
this week
it's been a rough week especially for
all of our childhoods but
i do what i have to do the decision is
not mine
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
youtube bans any conservative
questioning of the 2020 election process
17 states joined texas in suing states
where irregularities occurred
and a michigan democratic representative
threatens the lives of trump supporters
check it out on the michael knowles show